[Music]
you can never
return to schmergedoon
welcome to Schmidt
[Music]
oh yeah
shmika June was just the First Act
as the high of smigadoon starts to wear
off the realities of real life start to
set in it occurs to Josh couldn't we
maybe think about going back to schmidu
but what if we yes
this is not the kind of musical
yeah
this world of shimakago is a lot darker
hello the fans will be really shocked to
see this era of musicals filled with
mystery and villains allow me to
introduce myself our characters they
have darker histories darker Origins
stories set a new meat grinder
yep
it's sexier smokier boozier bluesier
okay I'm really into this yeah bring it
in pal I was determined to bring
everybody back but as a different
character apart from Keegan and Cecily
who are still Josh and Melissa it's the
mayor hey Mr Mayor I don't think that's
the mayor it's like we have our little
troop of Merry musical players and we
all get to play new roles
it's Sinister sexually diverse in a
wonderful way
[Music]
and the lighting and the production
design are working so well together and
such a beautiful and mysterious way
this season is going to be nuts they're
here
these musicals don't have happy ending
during time
thank you